نحن نتحدث عن غارات اسرائيليه متواصله
بالاضافه الى قنص اسرائيلي على كافه
المفترقات الواقعه في حي الرمال وفي مفترق
الطيران ومنطقه الطيران حتى هذه اللحظه
وصل عدد من الشهداء والكثير من الاصابات
اثر القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل بالاضافه
الى قنس قوات احتلال عشرات المواطنين لكن
مجملا انتشلت الاهالي شهيد من محيط مجمع
الشفاء الطبي برصاص قناصه اسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى وصول عدد من الاصابات من
محيط منطقه الصناعه والطيران برصاص القناص
القناصه وا ايه قذائف او اليات الاحتلال
قصفت ايه صيدليه الولاء التابعه للدكتور
محمد الحنجوري في تلك المنطقه خلال تفقده
للصيدليه ومحاولته اعطاء بعض الادويه
للمصابين قامت دبابات الاحتلال او اليات
الاحتلال بقصف هذه الصيدليه مما ادى الى
وقوع اربعه اصابات في هذه الصيدليه
الواقعه في محيط منطقه الطيران بالاضافه
الى ذلك انتشال شهيدين هما مازن حرز الله
ومحمد شوه الذان استشهدا برصاص القناصه
الاسرائيليه في منطقه حيا الصبر بالاضافه
الىى ذلك وجود عشرات الجثمان وفق شهادات
المواطنين في محيط منطقه الرمال ومحيط
منطقه الصناعه هم ملقون على الارض برصاص
القناصه وبقص الاسرائيلي المتواصل
بالاضافه الى ذلك هو وصول ثلاث اصابات من
المواطنين خلال تفقدهم الاراضي الزراعيه
في منطقه الشعف
ومحاوله يعني الاقتياد من بعض ما تبقى من
الاشجار او المناطق الزراعيه قامت مدفعيه
الاحتلال بقصف ثلاثه مواطنين مما ادى الى
ثلاث اصابات واحده بالغت الخطوره واثنتي
وصف بال المتوسطه القصف الاسرائيلي متواصل
في حين ان ايضا الاشتباكات مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه متواصله في منطقه جنوب غرب
مدينه غزه لا سما في وجود الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي تعلن عن تفجير الدبابات
وا قنص الجنود والكم لعدد من الجنود في
مختلف المناطق قبل لحظات اعلنت كتاب
المجاهدين عن تدمير دبابه في محيط منطقه
الصناعه بالاضافه الى الاستمرار
الاشتباكات و دوي الانفجارات في تلك
المنطقه مع استمرار تح د اليات قوات
الاحتلال وانتشار القناصه الاسرائيليه لكن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تنجح دائما في تدمير
بعض الاليات وقنص بعض الجنود وحتى الكم
لبعض افراد المشاه من القناصه من الجنود
الاسرائيليين